Did he reveal the name of the officier
who had recruited hi m?
The Tip of the Iceberg
Tunisia.. The hidden hands
Hidden hands have been messing
the Tunisian scene after the revolution
Files are being opened, while others are
meant to be kept away from the lights
and the people involved in this
are not to be held accountable
So, what are the facts
concealed in the locked drawers
and who is responsible for it?
Tunisia today is witnessing the most
complex scene since the revolution,
that broke out in 2011.
Acute political division and security files
are being exposed against the opponents
Inquiries about the extent of the judiciary's
intervention in settling political issues.
In this investigation,
The Tip of the Iceberg unfolds the file of
hidden roles behind crucial security events
which were witnessed in
Tunisia within the past decade.
Yet, the dominant hands
remained away from accountability
in favour of what appeared to be a
profound security and political system,
are still dominating the scene in Tunisia.
What is taking place nowadays
by those who are entirely
immersed in corruption and treason
These situations shouldn't last,
and such people shouldn't
be left without punishment.
Among the files that President
Kais Saied publicized before his opponents
A controversial file
within which the investigations included
the names of prominent opposition figures
at the top of the list are leaders
of the Ennahda movement.
The Jihadist-Migration file was put forward
in the media and the judiciary
at the peak of the political division
accusing officials, former
deputies and businessmen
affiliated with the opposition
because of facilitating the Jihadist-Migration
of thousands of young Tunisian people
after the Tunisian revolution
to join the fighters in the
so-called "trouble spots"
in Syria, Iraq and Libya.
As related to the senior leaders:
they, directly and indirectly, helped
spread the theme of terroristic crime
and the issue of sending Tunisian
youth to trouble spots such as Syria.
One of the names of
high importance in this file
and one of the prime witnesses
before the Tunisian Judiciary
"Essam Al-Dardouri".
The controversial figure of the security.
His name stood out on
more than one occasion.
He was also accused of leaking sensitive
calls with former security officials,
and several cases were filed against him.
All those who would be revealed by the
investigation were excluded by everyone.
I mean "Today..."
In light of the complex political
atmosphere in Tunisia nowadays,
the man was hosted by the
Tunisian, Arab, and international media.
He is one of the most mysterious and
controversial security men in Tunisia.
He was the first to reveal serious
terrorism and corruption files
within the Ministry of the
Interior during the past ten years.
He is also one of the few
who hold sensitive documents
related to his country's national security.
The security man and the President of
the Security and Citizen Organization,
Essam Al-Dardouri.
Ennahda Movement didn't just facilitate
the Jihadist-Migration process for
youth to the trouble spots
but also invested in it.
This Sheikh has some videos in
which he calls youth for Jihad in Syria,
which he can't deny.
Visiting all the Tunisian
prisons without prior authorisation
to deliver awareness lessons.
The Director General of
Prisons and Reformation
and the Director of Prison and Correctional
Units shall facilitate his mission.
Essam Al-Dardouri is a security unionist.
He used to work in security unions and
established an association linked to security.
He is also one of the
tools some parties use
to demonise the political scene,
in addition to striking some
political and security parties.
Essam Al-Dardouri is similar to others
who impersonate being a unionist.
They are being introduced after any
incident, security or terrorist incident.
The same media channels and the
same sites present them to the public
as experts, consultants,
or knowledgeable people.
Yet, they keep repeating the same ideas
and throwing the same accusations at the same political
parties that should be removed from the scene.
As for the security unions,
they are like a dagger stabbing
the heart of the Tunisian case.
They have been used
the worst by the deep state
to obstruct the Tunisian revolution's route
and to distort the political scene.
In this investigation,
The Tip of the Iceberg
has audio and visual leaks
associated with Essam Al-Dardouri.
Revealing a side of his hidden role,
in contrast to what he
pretends to be in public.
Greetings from the men of
the Islamic resistance in Syria
to the noble resistant man
"Essam Al-Dardouri"...
The message is nice, brother...
May God grant victory to the
resistance and all its members, brother.
May God make people
steadfast on the path, Allah willing.
I swear, brother, I had a nice and
unusual feeling when I heard this message
because this is the authentic and
genuine credit that remains for humans.
Prolonged audio-visual recordings
brought together Essam Al-Dardouri
with a mysterious Lebanese
man called "Muhammad Ali Ismael",
who works for the Syrian regime.
This leaked audio recording
reveals contact between both men
in order to secure an unofficial
rental of a number of Tunisian aircraft
assisted by Essam Al-Dardouri's
relations in Tunisia.
He said he wanted to
offer this project to you,
and I told him that we don't
want anything for free. OK?
If he can.. if we.. find someone
who can provide these planes
for domestic transportation.
Does it mean he could make this company
signoff with us under the research he's done?
The problem isn't about the
company's owner and who they are;
the problem is that we couldn't find
anyone close to the company's owner so far.
Because we don't want to go and discuss this matter
with him before guaranteeing his approval to help,
that's the problem.
I want that guy as soon as possible;
we have a 24-hour to the 48-hour deadline.
I requested my boss to give me
some time to sort this matter out,
do you get me?
If I could reach an agreement, he'll call
them tomorrow or the day after and fix it,
but now he's abroad, and I beseeched him
to allow me to intervene in this matter.
So, both you and I  be benefited.
Our friend, whom we met on some occasions, is a government
consultant, and he is at the Civil Aviation Authority.
He has relations with people in the
Civil Aviation Council and the airports.
So, he may be able to connect us with
the person we need within this context.
The man that the recordings prove to
have a relation with Essam Al-Dardouri
is "Muhammad Ali Ismael".
Who is known to some Tunisian security
services as Muhammad the Lebanese.
In one of his televised interviews, the
former head of the Air Force Protection,
Abdul Karim Al-Obeidi,
revealed his role.
The Jihadist-Migration started in
2003 until 2017 and 2018—
the Jihadist-Migration subject.
I have also given a name of
a person called "Geovanni"
who is the head of Jihadist-Migration in the
whole wide world and north Africa.
He was with a man called
"Muhammad the Lebanese".
It was significant that
Abdul Karim Al-Obeidi
is one of the security figures
who Essam Al-Dardouri
threw various accusations
associating him with the Jihadist-Migration
matter currently being raised.
There is a personal conflict
with representative Abdul Karim
Al-Obeidi and Ennahda Movement.
It is tragic yet comic at the same time
that Essam El Dardouri was accredited
as a primary witness in this case.
This person doesn't have the characteristics
of a witness from the legal point of view.
He has no credibility whatsoever.
Various incidents he
previously publically published
that were proven to be untrue lately.
Judicial sentences were
issued against him for it.
Among the leaked recordings we
managed to get for Essam Al-Dardouri.
An excitative recording.
It has to do with Al-Dardouri
leaking sensitive security information,
including a names-list of secret members
recruited by the Tunisian security abroad.
Regarding the CD containing the pictures
of the members responsible for permeation
who have trained at the security units. Have
you checked them all? Do you have all of them?
The recording? Is it working?
Yes, everything you gave to me is
clear. Yet, I couldn't take the CD with me.
So, I will try it in an alternative way.
But, overall, all is
going well, Allah willing.
Understood, brother; the recording, in particular, is
substantially important. It is very, very important.
Specifically, it has
something big we can work on.
What disturbs me is that I have been
imprisoned because of this recording.
The person speaking to me in the recording
is the Director General of National Security,
Abdul Rahman Haj Ali.
He is the one who filed a case against
me when he failed to get the recording.
Thanks.
The recording Al-Dardouri referred
to in his secret correspondence
is a phone call between him and the former
Director General of National Security,
Abdul Rahman Haj Ali.
Which Al-Dardouri had leaked a part of,
what provoked Abdul Rahman
Haj Ali to file a case against him,
and he was sentenced to imprisonment.
However, the verdict was appealed,
and the sentence was reduced to 4 months
in 2017.
Most importantly,
is that these audio recordings confirm
the accusations raised against Al-Dardouri
about communicating with foreign parties
and leaking confidential
security information abroad.
I contacted Essam
Al-Dardouri for an interview
and to comment on the accusations
against him in this investigation.
Peace be upon you, Mr Essam.
- Mr. Essam Al-Dardouri?
- Al Jazeera? Welcome, Sir.
We want to interview you
regarding the issue of Jihadist-Migration,
the topic currently discussed
in the Tunisian Judiciary.
If you have time.
I beg your pardon, Sir.
I'm a primary witness in this case,
and the case is still
considered confidential so far.
This means that it's forbidden to
release any information about it legally.
In this raised case, are you a witness
or, pardon me, an indicted Mr Essam?
No! No! I am one of the
primary witnesses in this file.
Because there was another case
discussed some
accusations of you personally.
What has been said about me is more
what Imam Malik has said about alcohol.
The accusations are
returned on who made them up.
Even concerning your
relationship with a Lebanese person
named "Muhammad Ismael",
has it been reopened...
No! No! There haven't been any investigations
against me regarding this matter in any context.
They were all false accusations. There is nothing
at all, and we have even appealed these issues.
Got it, brother? You're welcome anytime.
When it becomes no longer confidential,
and we can discuss it, I will.
But I can't discuss anything confidential.
Thank you for your time, Mr Essam.
You are welcome.
Despite Essam Al-Dardouri's promise of an
interview right after the legal approval,
yet shortly after our call with him,
he wrote a post on his Facebook page
attacking Al-Jazeera Channel
before broadcasting the investigation.
These leaks of audio
recordings and other ones
made us wonder about the
actual role played by Al-Dardouri
and to what extent he and others are used
as tools serving hidden
agendas and interests.
Their influence is still
present in the Tunisian scene
since the outbreak of the revolution.
In this investigation,
we managed to obtain several private
and confidential files and documents
investigating armed security
operations that took place in Tunisia.
While scrutinising them, the name
Essam Al-Dardouri appears in one of them.
In this leaked document,
Essam Al-Dardouri files a complaint
against one of the public prosecutors,
Hafeth Al-Obeidi
accusing him of seducing and
assaulting an underage girl in 2016.
Upon further scrutiny of the
identity of the Public Prosecutor,
it turns out that this judge
was directly responsible
for investigating the security operations
that rocked the country between 2015 and 2016.
The most significant operations
are the Mnihla operation
and the Bardo museum.
It is noteworthy that
the aforementioned girl
stated in the case records, according
to the documents we obtained,
that Essam El-Dardouri had exploited
her as a permeation agent as she described,
and she accused him of harassing her.
Lotfi Brahem deliberately assigned
the security unionist Essam Al-Dardouri
to overthrow
the investigating judge
and the assistant prosecutor
in moral matters,
so the file has been put aside until now.
Various lawyers have published
legal cases in Al-Manihla operation
because
the rotten political atmosphere
and the ailing faltering judiciary
left these files in desk drawers.
I arrived here
in the French capital, Paris,
in pursue to meet with security figures
who left Tunisia
and whose names were associated with
the recruitment of permeation members
for the benefit of
Tunisian security agencies.
Haykal Ad-Dakhil,
a former Tunisian security.
He took refuge in France in 2017.
The man was the head of the General Administration
of Prisons and Reform research team.
He is the one who opened an investigation
into the terrorist operation in Manihla.
Who supervised the investigation?
Yes, the one who supervised the investigation was
his assistant attorney general for terrorism cases.
They recruited a girl for him; she was barely 18
or 19 and studying for the baccalaureate then.
Regrettably, he was the assistant attorney
general at the time for terrorism cases,
and he was the one who opened an investigation
into the fabricated Manihla operation.
He also knew it was fabricated,
yet, he initiated the necessary investigations and
asked for labour, and the police worked with him.
I mean the competent
departments of the Ministry of Interior.
And they got all the correct information.
They know everything I'm telling you now.
Who are those involved
in Al-Manihla operation?
Unfortunately, they are security
leaders affiliated with the National Guard.
These people do not honour the state
because they are drenched
in blood up to the neck.
Al-Manihla operation:
It took place in May 2016,
when some units of the National Guard,
led by Lotfi Brahem at the time,
raided homes west of the Tunisian capital.
For intelligence
information that was received
about the presence of armed men
intending to carry out terrorist operations
inside Tunisia
According to a statement
of the Ministry of Interior,
the Tunisian authorities
announced at the time
that two gunmen were killed,
whom they described as dangerous,
in addition to the arrest of others
with the seizure of machine
guns, bombs and ammunition.
But a lot of doubts surround
this proactive operation.
As in this document we obtained,
the commander concluded the investigation based on what
he described as imbalances in the official accounts.
Which came in the words of the
spokesman of the National Guard
that Al-Manihla operation
was a fabricatedcrime.
This file is an absolute scandal
for the security services
that demonstrated the role of some parties
in creating terrorism
instead of working to suppress these acts.
Of course, there are political figures,
as the security services only act
under cover from political parties,
who were working to return Tunisia
to the tyranny period by
using the card of terrorism.
- As for the group in Al-Manihla, was it all Tunisians?
- Yes.
Were they all inside the country?
Are their names known?
Are they openly linked to terrorist groups?
One of the surprises that
accompanied Al-Manihla's operation
and confirmed the dangerous tampering
with the terrorism file in Tunisia
was that one of those
arrested in Al-Manihla
was the famous Adel Al-Ghandari.
Who is one of the leaders of ISIS,
whom the Tunisians thought and
various media channels announced
the news of his arrest in Libya
and his handover to the Tunisian
authorities at the border crossing
two or three months before
the Al-Manihla operation.
To the public surprise
that the same Ministry of the Interior
is talking about the arrest of Adel
Al-Ghandari in Al-Manihla operation
among a terrorist group that was planning to
target an American military man in Tunisia.
This raises several questions
and causes a lot of suspicions.
Yet, unfortunately, no one dared,
or perhaps no one could overcome
the phobia that occurred to officials and
judges as everyone seemed to be afraid
and did not want to go
through any further into this file.
In this investigation, we reviewed
the leaked records of the people
arrested testimonies in Al-Manihla case.
It was noted in their testimonies
the repetition of the title of An-Nimer
when they gave information about the identity of the
person supervising their recruitment and movements
a mysterious figure
whose real name was not
mentioned in the actual file.
In Al-Manihla file, the
investigation judge stated
that An-Nimr
had been assigned as a permeation member
under the supervision of the
National Guard Department.
As for An-Nimer, he is likely
the prime permeation member.
An-Nimr is the one who carried out all the
operations associated with Al-Manihala operation.
He also was the one
who collected the accused
and transferred them to Tunis, the capital,
where he rented places forthemtolive.
Is An-Nimr a member of the National Guard?
No! An-Nimr is a civilian
who was previously tried in 2007-2008
in a case of a terrorist nature.
It seems he was recruited during that period
in prison by one of the security services
and became known to them.
According to his testimony,
he is in direct contact with
the leaders of ISIS abroad.
They also endorsed him; he speaks
and acts in their name in Tunisia.
The documents reveal that the
Tunisian National Guard administration
deliberately concealed the roles that
An-Nimr during Al-Manihla's operation
from the Public Prosecution Office, which
was legally responsible for directing him.
The police report stated
that An-Nimr could not be interrogated
or determine his true identity.
Therefore, he was not brought to trial.
The operation was out of
the supervision of the judiciary,
and permission to infiltrate
this member was not obtained
until the night of the execution
of Al-Manihla operation.
That means subsequent
legal coverage of an illegal act.
If these groups
were actual terrorist groups
and were preparing to
commit attacks in the capital,
the man named An-Nimr would
have been the first accused.
Because he was the one who gathered them,
he was the one who rented houses for them
and sheltered them.
Yet, he is entirely
absent from the case file.
The summary of the investigation
leaders in Al-Manihla case
reveals another hidden side.
The Kalashnikov weapon
that An-Nimr handed over
to the group that was raided in Al-Manihla
was, basically, a weapon previously
confiscated by the National Guard,
and it was handed over after
the needle was removed from it
to the group before the
intervention squad arrived.
The Kalashnikov they found
in Al-Manihla's operation
was not used because this Kalashnikov
was one of the weapons that were impounded
among the weapons that we found in 2012.
First, 2012, then plenty of weapons stores
were inspected by the
military and security units.
They were all secured,
meaning that each weapon,
Kalashnikov, had a number registered with
and recorded in a special booklet
before it was taken to the store.
The Kalashnikov that the terrorists
used in Al-Manihla's operation
were the same weapon used
by the terrorists in Al-Manihla.
So, this means it was in one of the stores?
Yes, in one of the stores.
But how did this weapon come out?
No one can get it out except
for a High-ranked commander,
not a simple person working in security.
Despite the ambiguity of An-Nimr's
identity in the official investigations
yet, later, he
initiated contact with one of those
we interviewed in this investigation,
Maher Zaid.
Who has been personally active
in tracing what happened in Al-Manihla.
Did you meet Al-Nimer in person?
Yes, I met Al-Nimer. He
contacted me on social media.
After I started talking about
this subject, he called me.
On what date?
In October 2016.
Four months after the operation.
He requested to meet me.
So I gave him that opportunity
after I took his word that
I would not be harmed.
He admitted,
during that meeting, that he had been
working with the security services for years.
But, according to what he
said, he wanted to correct
some of the information that was inaccurately
mentioned about himself and his role.
Like what?
For example, he seized
vast sums of money
from the people he gathered.
Of course, he did not
give me his real identity.
I noticed that his mother called frequently
and was interrupting our conversation.
He showed me the phone and
said, “Look! That's my mother.
Due to being terrified of
the pressure I'm exposed to
after my name has been leaked.
Also, those who have been arrested and are
still in prison in Al-Manhila operation.
They will definitely lead
counterparts and others to target me.”
When we searched for the account that
An-Nimr used to communicate with Maher Zaid,
we found out that the username had
been deleted and is no longer in use.
In this investigation, we met the
Tunisian activist Al-Saheb Al-Omari,
imprisoned due to political cases.
This man reveals the
true identity of An-Nimr,
based on information
he received inside prison.
Someone originally from Ghardan
told me about the
permeation inside the prison
and wanted me to be cautious
in mixing with dishonest people.
Mainly that people felt
that there were permeations.
One of them told me about
someone called An-Nimr.
An-Nimr
was imprisoned and infiltrated
the Salafi Jihadi group.
Yet, when he was released
after serving his prison term,
when he was leaving prison,
he joined Salafist groups
stationed in Sparta.
His name is Khalil Al-Sidani.
A resident of At-Tadamon neighborhood,
and that he is a spy.
He brought and recruited forty young men
40 young men for the
operation of Al-Manihla.
The records of the detainees in the case
reveal the roles played by An-Nimr
in managing the group he recruited.
One of the detainees says in his testimony
that An-Nimr brought a weapon with him
and gave lessons in assembly, disassembly
and theoretical shooting
to prepare the group members
to carry out operations
on the Tunisian lands.
According to the statement of
another detainee, the so-called An-Nimr
suggested carrying out operations
to target the National Guard agents
and the isolated security patrols.
And the testimony of a third
detainee clarifies
that one of the targets
identified by An-Nimr
was an American general
who frequently visited the
officers' club in Al-Hammamet area.
So, what is the interest of
An-Nimr to define those targets?
Tunisia is engaged in
combating international terrorism
with American support; however,
since the descent of the
pattern of terrorism in Tunisia,
the grant did not exceed
forty million dinars.
Mr (What is his name!)
Mr Lotfi Brahem agreed
and formed a criminal alliance
to pressure America
to return the regular expenses
that come in bags,
bags of money.
Why did it come in bags
and not throw bank transfers?
Due to the privacy and
confidentiality of the mission.
Fellow officers
devised (and he was with them)
a ploy to blackmail the United States
into combating terrorism,
and they started
fabricating terrorist incidents.
Not only the operation of Manhila
but other operations of
Sidi Bouzaid and others.
Did he reveal to you the name
of the officer who recruited him?
Yes, An-Nimr, is no
different than others like him,
among the members of permeation
who were used for these missions,
talked to us all through those years
and all of them, without exception,
were talking about a figure called
Al-Pasha, a person named Al-Pasha.
Who is a senior officer in the Guard;
he was in charge of managing these spies.
He communicated with them and
gave them instructions and cash.
Either for themselves or
to carry out some missions.
Did he reveal to you the
actual name of Al-Pasha?
No, he did not reveal the
actual name of Al-Pasha to me;
he only gave me his number.
It has been said that the one responsible
for creating the permeation members
is Al-Pasha.
- Yes, Al-Pasha.
- Who is Al-Pasha?
Al-Pasha is a Brigadier General
in the Guard named Khaled Hanish.
- Do you know him personally?
- Yes, I know him.
I will tell you how I knew him personally.
I went to the research group one day.
I went and met him.
We talked about several things; then
he asked me: Do you know An-Nimr?
I told him: Yes, I know An-Nimr.
Then I showed him the conversation
between him and me on my phone.
The conversation?
Yes, the conversation. Because he knows that I am a man of
security following instructions and I have nothing to worry about.
I told him: do you know that
An-Nimr knows Maher Zaid?
And here was the catastrophe
and surprise, my friend.
- I saw the man's face...
- Changed!
It became yellow.
He said: Maher Zaid?
I told him: Yes, Maher Zaid knows An-Nimr,
and they met in At-Tadamon neighbourhood.
So he went out to make a phone
call and returned after five minutes.
He said: Haykal, come with me to Owainat.
I told myself: that's exactly what I
want; I want to know this beehive
that is causing the natural
disasters in Tunisia, and who they are.
The Pasha is the Brigade General,
Khaled Hniche.
He is an agent for foreign intelligence
and they pay him a fortune
within the framework of
International Cooperation.
His job is to choose permeation agents.
An-Nimr is one of them;
by no means can An-Nimr be the only one.
In this investigation,
we obtained confidential testimony
from a spy who the Tunisian
Security Forces recruited.
According to this man, he has been assigned
to transport money, and
the wanted armed men
between Libya and the
Tunisian mountains at the border.
Now, I have been
officially assigned a mission.
I created an account on Telegram
to contact Mr At-Taher Al-Gharbi in Libya,
accompanied by Bachindi in the mountains.
So, I went to Libya
and called Mr At-Taher Al-Gharbi,
and agreed to the operation terms.
I get 1500 dinars for every wanted
person I deliver to Bin Gardane
and 1000 dinars for every unwanted person
as they have people in Bin
Gardane to complete the mission.
We sought more information
about more permeative spies
recruited by the National Guards.
Zeinab Kachroud, a Tunisian recruited
to deliver money to the
armed groups in the mountains
on the Tunisian Algerian borders.
Yet, during one of her missions, she got
arrested by the Algerian Security Forces.
We were able to get
a letter written by her.
From her jail in Algeria,
she wrote it in March 2019.
She addressed the letter to the Public
Persecutor for combating terrorism in Tunisia,
imploring him to admit that she
was on a mission assigned to her
to infiltrate the terrorist groups.
Sir, I do not want to seek help
from Algeria to get my rights
but instead ask you, the
Tunisian Republic, my country,
to interfere and get my right.
As I haven't forgotten
the day I was recruited
and the promise you made back then
that I shall not be harmed.
I hope you will take responsibility
because I am still under your legal and
humanitarian obligation,
and despite all I have been through,
I still fully trust you.
She is one girl among many others
recruited to infiltrate
the terrorist groups
and was asked at some point
- by the same officer supervising all missions.
- Al-Pasha.
Yes, and this orientation operation.
He sent the girl to the border
between Tunisia and Algeria,
where dozens of armed men hid out.
Equally divided between Tunisians and Algerians
and some individuals from other nationalities.
She was arrested on Algerian territories,
and she was presented to the court.
The persecutor was shocked.
The Algerian?
The Chief Algerian Persecutor at
the Court of Bab El Wadi, Algiers.
He was shocked that the
"terrorist" before him told him:
I am a patriot working for
my own country assigned
by the National security forces to
infiltrate those armed men in the mountains.
So, he allowed her to communicate with
the security office that had assigned her.
But, unfortunately, that security office
forsaken and denied any relation to her.
So, she spent five whole
years in jail in Algeria
after being charged with being
a member of a terrorist group.
I have been humiliated and threatened to be
killed.
Neither did the state compensate me nor
give me a job.
I am not asking for money but for
their protection. I don't need the money.
Help me get out of Tunisia. I
do not want to live here any more.
My country will remain
even if it mistreats me,
but I cannot live between death threats by
armed groups and the state's negligence.
I have served the Tunisia State,
and for that, it must protect me.
Regarding An-Nimr, is he still in Tunisia?
Yes, An-Nimr is still in Tunisia.
As a free man?
He has the absolute freedom
to move anywhere.
After the exculpation of all of them
and confidence that what
had happened was a mere play
and after the National Guards
were killed and martyrised.
Until today, all those
involved in this crime are free,
as it is the case with all other crimes.
Another armed attack in
the heart of Tunis, the capital.
Two armed men attacked the Bardo Museum,
near the Tunisian Parliament,
in March 2015.
It ended with killing more than 20
people, most of whom were tourists,
and injuring about 50 others.
Security forces immediately intervened
and announced later, arresting those
involved in the attack.
The Persecutor's report on the Bardo attack
mentioned:
that a wide falsification of the incidents
was due to confessions under torture.
Philippe De Veulle, one of the lawyers
representing the victims of the Bardo attack,
whose investigations are still ongoing
as this report is being broadcasted.
Mr Philippe, you were among the lawyers
representing the French
victims of the Bardo attack.
What are the most significant faults and
loopholes, in this case, Mr Philippe?
Well, at the first stage of this case,
I was surprised to learn of the
absence of security in the Bardo Museum,
and that was the first
thing I publicly denounced.
O my God! How can a country like Tunisia
depend on only two unarmed security
guards to protect Bardo Museum
among all the security threats
in the region at that time?
To me, that was the first fault
from the side of the Tunisian State.
Tunisian media reported on
a security document directed to
the Head of National Security
requesting him to secure the
area around the Bardo Museum
about ten days before the attack,
based on confirmed information
that armed groups are
planning to attack the site,
according to the document.
Afterwards, the Tunisian Ministry of
Interior rushed to deny this document.
However, this raised many questions
about the backstage of the
armed attacks nationwide.
Have you found ties
between the Tunisian State
and its security forces
to the Bardo attack?
With time we find out more and more
that it was an obvious lack of security,
but, in fact, it may also
have to do with something
that had been preplanned
by a secret organisation
of the Tunisian State at that time.
I have no evidence to prove this,
but this is actually something
that we can think about.
The same team was working,
and not only did the permeation
take place by
those directly working with Lotfi Brahem
but also by corrupt officials, spies
and affiliates to foreign powers
working in the security forces,
were also conducting the same methods.
Lotfi Brahem
was named the head of
the National Guards in 2015
at the time when the terrorist
attacks peaked all over the country.
We are here to fight terrorism. We discover
armed cells every day all over the country.
Among many, we found in this document
that the persecutor
assigned to the Mnihla Case
clearly states that Lotfi Brahem,
the head of the National Guards,
directly interfered with covering
up the breaches in this case.
Mr Lofti Brahem, Minister of Interior.
Lotfi Brahem was assigned to be the Minister
of Interior by PM Youssef Chahed in 2017.
... and to protect its interests.
The French writer and
journalist Nicolas Beau,
the expert on Tunisian affairs,
had revealed in many of his articles
multiple secrets of the politicians
and security officials in Tunisia
for decades.
Within the last few years, his
name was often associated with
revealing a classified document
on Lotfi Brahem's controversial
role in an attempted coup.
The thing that made
Brahem sue Nicolas Beau.
Mr Nicolas, you had mentioned
a leaked, classified document
on the time when Lotfi Brahem was
head of the Tunisian National Guards.
This document proves as
you said, his preparations
to divert the political route in Tunisia.
What document is that?
And what does is exactly state?
We saw in this document that
it had been proven afterwards
that Lotfi Brahem has founded
many strong bonds with politicians,
He had strong ties in
various Tunisian governorates
with members of the National Guards
involved in smuggling across the borders.
Many people succeeded
in gaining his loyalty,
politicians, security forces
and even business people.
He was evidently ambitious.
Mid-2018,
Lotfi Brahem was dismissed
during the rule of former
president Beji Caid Essebsi
after reports of him attempting a coup.
Remarkably, days after Brahem's
dismissal from the Ministry of Interior,
an armed attack targeted
members of the National Guards.
and killed six of them in the Jendouba
Governorate, bordering Algeria.
There are two hypotheses:
The first is that the National
Guards were weakened
by dismissing its leaders
and that the terrorist
groups took advantage of that
to kill six of the National
Guards in the heart of Tunisia.
The hypothesis that many
newspapers in Tunisia supported.
There is another hypothesis:
states that Lotfi Brahem
in order to show that his presence and his assistants
are crucial to maintaining security in Tunisia,
is why he arranged this terrorist
attack. And that would be very easy to do.
Once again, Lotfi Brahem's
name was popular in the media
to come to power again as the Minister of Interior
in the current government of President Kais Saied.
Today, Lotfi Brahem is
roaming in the same spots
where people close to
Kais Saied are located.
He was strongly nominated to
become the Minister of Interior,
and until today, he advises Kais
Saied's team with his experience.
During this investigation, we
tried to contact Lotfi Brahem
to answer our inquiries and respond
to the accusations in this investigation.
The number you are calling
is currently unavailable.
Please leave a message after the tone
or try to call again later.
Mr Maher, you mentioned an organisation
directing these incidents.
Who are the members of this organisation?
The head of this organisation is abroad.
They were significantly affected
by the Arab Spring of 2011
and were afraid to catch the
"infection" in their own countries.
Of course, the classical
enemy, the French institutions
that are in direct contact with them
and they never spare a chance to
shamelessly and fully defend France
they defend its interests.
When you accuse the French State
of conspiring with the Tunisian State,
in an operation like Bardo, for instance.
What do you mean?
Do you mean a conspiracy
on the intelligence level?
Or do you mean that the
French State has evidence of
its friends in Tunisia being involved in
those attacks?
It is a question I still have in my mind.
One thing is quite apparent.
When I accused the Tunisian judge.
At that time, the French Judge,
Isabelle Cosie surprised us all.
All of us,
not only me
and told all the victims:
Please do not touch Tunisia.
It seems like a no-go zone.
It is best not to accuse
the Tunisian State.
I was totally shocked.
When I spoke to President Hollande,
I was confident that he
would understand that.
He did listen to me.
But the question is: why hasn't
he done anything to help us?
Have you found any explanation for that?
Well, perhaps you should
ask President Hollande about it
or ask Macron about his silence about it.
Seven years have passed
since the Mnihla operation.
No generals or officials
accused of planning it were sued,
as per the leaked documents.
Another eight years after
the Bardo Museum Attack,
the Tunisian Judicial System has not yet ruled,
until the broadcast of this investigation,
and many other cases are still pending.
As the names and professions of the State
officials connected to those cases vary,
the talk starts again about
the existence of the deep State
that rules the scene nowadays in Tunisia.
A state that the judicial system cannot
approach nor can be held accountable.
The Deep State seeks to cover
up some of the political bodies
involved in those breaches
and reinvent terrorism and provocate it.
There is no other explanation.
And those involved in those breaches
are all enjoying immunity today
or, in other words, not being punished,
and the law has not been enforced.
There is no doubt that
the Deep State controls
every aspect of the Tunisian State,
the judicial system, the security forces,
and even the political power.
It does not want to let the
Tunisian people enjoy any freedom.
It wants to hinder the Tunisians on their
way to freedom, democracy and development.
It is the main hindrance to realise
the goals of the Tunisian Revolution.
What is the organisation
that rules Tunisia nowadays?
In consideration of the talk about a
Deep State controlling all aspects?
Yes, exactly.
I believe that it is an organisation.
On the geographical level,
they belong to the Tunisian shore,
the region that was always in control
of the political system in Tunisia.
The people of the shore normally support
each other,
undoubtfully aiming to reinstall the power
that remained for an
extended period in their hands
during the eras of Bourguiba and Ben Ali.
That they lost in 2011.
I believe that General Ben Ali,
who had ruled for 17 years,
succeeded in one important thing:
he established a strong police state.
He succeeded in that because
the Tunisian army was weak.
The president used
to control all the powers
which the Ministry of Interior controlled
and has indeed established what we
call the Deep State or the Police State.
Kais Saied, just like Ben Ali, is
relying on this Police Organisation
and this Deep State.
Now that he is the head of
state, why doesn't he take action?
He cannot. Why?
Because he cannot take any single action.
These documents are classified
and will remain classified forever.
These documents shall
always remain classified.
You were in the parliament when Ennahda Movement
was part of the ruling power in Tunisia.
Why were you silent about this topic
at a time when you were
able to do something about it?
I think that Ennahda Movement
avoided dealing with those people
because it knew very well, which is true,
that many political powers had their back
and created allies and full coordination
to govern the country for ten years.
So it avoided every possible chance to
force any serious and correct investigation
into such crimes.
Today, if we look back, they
have paid a very high price.
Have they made a wrong
decision and this vision?
Yes, our friends in Ennahda Movement,
in closed discussions, admit that
all the terrorist attacks
were aimed against them
and the whole Tunisian
democratic route in general
and specific humane values,
but they were not on the
required level of courage.
They thought that the ties and alignments
they had created with political parties,
as per their best thought at that time,
that being allies with them is better
than facing them in judicial battles,
which has led to all that
has happened on 25/07/2021.
A security and political organisation
is controlling the scene in Tunisia.
The political route was
diverted and changed,
but this organisation has effectively
maintained its control over the whole scene.
Backstage, many security
incidents of the last decade
were only scenarios and
conspiracies to settle internal matters
and to realise a cross-border agenda
and that's only the Tip of the Iceberg.